A fellow knitter, Mary, was lamenting that
the Jaggerspun of Maine Mill was closing.
She said, I love their Superlamb 4/8.
What can I substitute?
Now, the best way to find a similar yarn
is to first look for the fiber you like.
The Superlamb was 100%
superwash wool on cones.
Sadly, there are very few choices for us
here in the US for any yarn on cones.
Let's take a look at yarn
on balls or hanks.
Yarn is often classified by the Craft Yarn
Council numbering system, one through six.
But here are two ways
that can be more accurate.
First, look at yards per pound.
Using the Knitted Now Vintage Yarn Index,
we can see that the Superlamb had
approximately 1120 yards per pound.
Our Yarn Index is a listing of vintage
yarns that you can use for reference,
especially when using vintage patterns.
Looking at the Knitpicks Wool
of the Andes Superwash, it has
approximately 110 yards per 50 grams.
Using the Knit It Now Yards per Pound
Tool, we can calculate that
110 yards in a 50 gram ball is
approximately 997 yards per pound.
Comparing a 1120 to 997,
we can tell that the Knit Picks yarn will
be heavier than what she was using,
and it won't give her the same
hand or drape she's used to.
Let's look at another yarn.
Here's an old standby,
the Lion brand Wool Ease.
It's listed as having
180 meters in 85 grams.
The tool tells us that this is
approximately 1,050 yards per pound.
Now, this may knit up closer
to what Mary had used in the past.
The second way to compare yarns
is to look at the suggested gauge.
The Wool of the Andes is listed as 18
to 20 stitches to 4 inches, and the Wool
Ease is 18 stitches to 4 inches.
In addition to the yards per pound,
comparing these gauges to what she used
with her original yarn will give her
even more information to compare.
Using yards per pound and the gauge is much
more accurate way of comparing yarn than
the Craft Yarn Council numbering system.